[Music]
on this sunday night the on and off
again evacuation order in bc
the stress facing water weary residents
we just purchased this house six months
ago it's very very frightening the
string of storms drenching the region
and the threat coming from south of the
border detecting omicron more countries
report cases of the new variant is
canada next
officers under scrutiny in quebec the
investigation into what witnesses say
was a violent arrest plus oh christmas
tree why it won't be so easy to find
these lovely branches
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin in british columbia where
areas hard hit by flooding two weeks ago
have seen another deluge of rain the
second in a series of atmospheric rivers
moved into the region but that isn't the
only source of concern the nook sac
river located across the border in
washington state is overflowing and that
over abundance of water is heading
toward abbotsford bc and that's where we
find our heather urex west heather the
city has issued an evacuation order and
then there's the issue of the floodgates
of the pumping station being closed walk
us through these latest developments
yeah these are all developments that
have just happened in the last little
while so with these floodgates being
closed that means more water is going
into the sumas river which is of course
the concern the good news is is that
however since last week's flooding the
dikes that failed along the sumas river
have been repaired but of course having
more water into that river is going to
put more pressure on those dikes so we
will be watching that closely as well as
you mentioned the nook sack river is
flooding its banks about 3 15 local time
we heard the air raid sirens go off on
the other side of the border this is an
american warning system in place to
alert residents that there is flooding
occurring online they posted to
residents there that they may have only
a short time to evacuate before the
roads become impassable so the situation
on the washington side of the border is
serious and we do know that the water is
traveling across the border towards this
abbotsford neighborhood and the city is
just not taking any chances
margaret olay is packed up and ready to
go her abbotsford neighborhood is under
an evacuation order as the nooksack
river in washington state continues to
swell
yeah a little bit stressed we hope the
dyke will will hold there you know the
army built
a good dike there
more than a hundred soldiers worked with
area residents to build a sandbag
barrier around the neighborhood saturday
night but by sunday morning residents
were told they could not stay it's very
hard like i just recently moved to this
neighborhood
we just purchased this house six months
ago
and yeah it's it's very
very frightening amman kang spent a
sleepless night worrying what the day
would bring a total of 90 homes in this
neighborhood have been evacuated though
not everyone has been willing to leave
abbotsford police warning that could be
a dangerous mistake at some point if the
water does come and we anticipate it
coming there might be an opportunity
where we can't get to everyone at one
time safely so
we want people to leave as soon as
possible we're in the middle of one of
the most intense series of storms that
we have seen along coastal bc
this is historic weather intensified by
climate change
the interior and southwest areas
continue to see heavy rains with more on
the way there are now flood warnings and
watches in place across large areas of
the province including parts of
vancouver island the lower mainland the
fraser valley and the interior on
saturday parts of several major highways
were closed as a precaution since then
the province says there have been a
number of minor slides onto the roadways
the heavy rains expected only to ease
for a short time monday before b.c is
hammered by another major storm
and the rain continues to fall over the
last 24 hours the city has seen 100
millimeters of rain so that continues to
be a concern and the knucksack river
south of the border is not expected to
crest until later this evening so this
is in fact a developing story and one
that we will continue to watch tonight
robin and the rain certainly isn't going
away heather yorick's west in abbotsford
bc
the canadian armed forces have been
deployed to merit bc to help strengthen
the city's flood defenses just hours
after being allowed to return home for
the first time in nearly two weeks
two-thirds of the people living in the
city were forced out this afternoon at
first they were allowed day access to
their properties but that plan has been
suspended because of concerns that a
nearby river could overflow
so there is a dramatic amount of water
that will be coming down the river and
causing water water levels to rise
possibly to bank full and there is a
risk of flooding tonight as a result of
this
two weeks ago the entire city with a
population of seven thousand was placed
under an evacuation order when flood
waters overwhelmed the water treatment
facility
for a look at how unprecedented this
rain is let's bring in meteorologist
yvonne shell yvonne give us a sense of
how much rain is involved with this
second system
rob and the latest atmospheric river
taking aim along the south coast
bringing upwards of 100 millimeters for
a few areas it is tapering off we'll be
at the tail end we'll look at the chance
of showers for the afternoon and leading
in towards the evening in behind it a
brief break but then the next weather
maker is going to move in and this
atmospheric river packing a punch once
again as it moves for both the north
central and southern areas along the
coast now we are going to see an
increase for the freezing level once
again into early next week the big
concern snow melt that will contribute
to the runoff and that'll increase the
risk of flooding we're looking
additional amounts with this next storm
that'll be tuesday leading in towards
wednesday we're watching the numbers
closely so far we are on track for the
wettest fall on record for abbotsford
victoria and vancouver robin okay thanks
for that yvonne
we have breaking news out of ontario
that province has confirmed two cases of
the omicron variant the drug makers
behind the vaccines are closely watching
this mutation of the virus they already
know the delta variant can cause
breakthrough cases in fully vaccinated
people as sarah comedina reports the
hospitalization rates will be key in
understanding whether this new variant
poses a problem
covid 19 cases in alberta have dropped
dramatically in recent weeks but one
alberta doctor says there is no time to
rest we're plateauing it you know 350 to
450 cases a day which is a lot let's
let's be honest that's a lot
and so we need to be doing better even
with the situation that we have on the
ground now the delta variant is still
affecting thousands in the province
emergency room doctor joe vaipon worries
now that the new omicron variant is here
it could worsen the situation with the
policies that we have on the ground at
the moment it's failing for delta so if
we get a more transmissible variant in
here we will just fail much worse vipond
appreciates the quick action by the
federal government to place strict
measures for people traveling from
southern africa but he believes more
needs to be done he is calling on the
province to get rid of the masking
exemption for school-aged kids and to
bring in better enforcement of vaccine
and masking policies it's better to
overreact and then pull back and say oh
that was that was an overreaction rather
than under react it's not a feeling
shared by all doctors in the country
ottawa icu doctor claudio caramentang
says canada doesn't have to worry just
yet i think it's too early to push the
panic button but just to be cognizant
and you know continue to listen to
public health he says canada's high
vaccination rate may prevent an increase
in hospitalizations and deaths it
circulates in a population that's highly
vaccinated you might see cases go up but
how does it translate into
hospitalization this is the true
protector while there are many unknowns
about this new variant health officials
from across the country say one thing is
certain getting vaccinated remains to be
your best defense against the virus
sarah comedina global news edmonton
meanwhile the south african government
is calling for calm as more countries
impose travel limits on foreign
nationals from parts of africa
omicron is showing up in several
countries and as far away as australia
tonight israel has decided to close its
borders to outsiders altogether michael
couture reports
[Music]
calls for calm to counter covet 19
hysteria are going mostly unheated in
south africa as residents get vaccinated
i am worried because well it's
apparently more dangerous than the
previous one due to mutations all the
while one of the first south african
doctors to suspect there was a new
variant says so far symptoms related to
omicron are milder compared to other
variants not saying the virus is not
going to give you severe infections
but the whole hype out there
doesn't make any sense medical sins at
this stage
despite that more countries are banning
travel from south african countries as
they detect cases of the variant within
their borders
the dutch health minister says 13 new
omicron cases have been found in the
netherlands and australia has detected
two cases both countries have imposed
travel bans on people from a number of
south african countries south africa's
president calls the move unjustified and
discriminatory the prohibition of travel
is not informed by science
nor will it be effective in preventing
the spread of this variant israel is
going one step further closing its
borders to all four nationals for 14
days in an effort to prevent the spread
of the new variant starting monday
morocco is suspending all incoming air
travel for two weeks the president of
the european commission says the eu
is in a race against time
and the scientists and manufacturer need
two to three weeks to have a full
picture
about the quality of the mutations of
this omicron variant
that need for more time and research
echoed by the us's top infectious
disease official the profile of the
mutations strongly suggests that it's
going to have an advantage in
transmissibility and that it might evade
immune protection it's why the world's
largest covid19 vaccine manufacturers
are gearing up research teams both
moderna and pfizer biontech say a
vaccine tailored for the omicron variant
could be ready by early 2022
if it's needed
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
in quebec city police are investigating
the arrests of two black teenagers this
weekend a video circulating on social
media shows police officers aggressively
pinning down the teens and even kicking
snow in one of their faces the teens are
no longer in custody but it's not clear
if they were even charged raquel
fletcher reports and a warning the video
you're about to see is disturbing
bystanders shot these videos friday
night on quebec city's popular grand
alley police officers arresting two
black teenagers dragging this girl and
pushing her face into the snow an
officer also appears to deliberately
kick snow into the face of this
17-year-old boy witnesses shout out in
horror
the teen is a young refugee who recently
moved to canada his boxing coach says he
was appalled to see the video online
he's a good kid he says always smiling
while an internal investigation is
underway the quebec city mayor is asking
police to answer for their actions which
he called disturbing the province's
minister responsible for the fight
against racism tweeting the videos
raised questions and he will be
following the investigation closely
there was also strong reaction sunday
morning at quebec's liberal party
convention not far from the scene of the
arrests it was really troubling liberal
leader dominic onglad says an internal
investigation is insufficient she's
calling for an independent inquiry to
get to the bottom of what exactly
happened and whether the arrests and the
officer's behavior were racially
motivated i don't want to conclude that
this is because of
this is because of systemic racism i
mean we need to have an independent but
it does raise the question it does raise
the question this activist says while
racial profiling is hard to prove the
video does show something very wrong the
question i'm sure most of the public is
wondering is especially the one who put
his boot full of snow in the kid's face
why is this man still working today
liberal m a greg kelly tabled a petition
in 2019 to equip police officers with
body cams he says this would have helped
to put friday's events in context
government seems to be dragging its feet
i think that's at least one thing we can
do quickly to help provide some more
confidence
in the relations between our citizens
and police forces relations that remain
tense particularly when it involves
people of color raquel fletcher global
news quebec city
coming up the migrant crisis sparks a
fight between france and britain
a violent 7.5 magnitude earthquake
rocked northern peru early today it
struck in the amazonis region about 800
kilometers from the capital but it was
felt in lima peru's president is vowing
support to those affected by structural
damage no deaths have been reported the
quake struck at a depth of 112
kilometers something that can limit
damage and death
there was an emergency meeting in europe
today to address the urgent issue of
migrant smuggling it follows the tragic
drownings of more than two dozen
migrants in the english channel last
week the deadliest incident on record in
the stretch of waters separating great
britain and mainland europe the
situation has left france and the uk at
odds with one another and as jennifer
johnson explains britain was left out of
today's talks
it's okay it's okay overnight the
italian coast guard rescued about 250
migrants including a newborn baby from a
boat bad weather and high seas
complicated the more than 16 hour rescue
they come from places like iran and
north africa escaping poverty slavery
and conflict in northern france hundreds
of migrants are huddled in makeshift
camps cold and hungry but determined to
cross the english channel despite the
recent capsizing that left 27 dead no
fear
no fear water if we die
sorry i say that but we already died
nobody accept us anyway french
authorities routinely dismantle these
camps coastlines are heavily patrolled
but the migrants are willing to wait the
police is right now everywhere
they don't let us go to
in the water they are really secure
in the beach
right now
but most of them they wait for the
situation go normal leaders from several
european nations met sunday to try to
fix the crisis britain was notably
absent the french interior minister
canceled the uk's invitation after harsh
words were exchanged between leaders of
the two countries
migrant crossings in the mediterranean
and atlantic seas have more than tripled
this year after european borders
reopened as coven 19 cases decreased
but the weather is getting colder and
survival is becoming more difficult for
those seeking a better life coughs and
colds last longer and longer they also
then become worse so there's more chance
of getting
worse diseases such as pneumonia quanti
migrante pope francis made an
impassioned appeal sunday to european
nations to respect the migrants humanity
while a vigil was held on folk stone
beach in england to honor those who lost
their lives in the english channel
jennifer johnson global news
still ahead studies show patients who
have covered may develop diabetes
you're watching global national
tonight there is more evidence that
covet 19 can harm your health in other
ways two studies supported by the
national institute of health in the
united states found some patients who
contracted the virus developed diabetes
there are several theories as to why
this virus may trigger the disease jamie
morocco explains
a doctor's visit for long covered
symptoms left vancouver resident craig
spanzo with a surprising post-virus
diagnosis he did a bunch of tests and
yeah my glucose he said was
off the charts
rapid onset type 2 diabetes in covid
patients is something being investigated
globally including out of mcmaster
university in hamilton ontario where a
2020 study found up to 14 percent of
people who were hospitalized with covid
later developed the disease we believe
there is evidence that short-term covet
is leading to diabetes montreal
specialist remy rabazar says while the
virus itself may be damaging cells that
produce insulin he isn't ruling out that
steroids used to treat covid patients
may actually be the cause at johns
hopkins school of medicine
endocrinologist dr maheel zilberman
agrees you know that high dose of
steroid therapy which is indicated for
patients with covet 19
can aggravate
high blood sugar
and it is possible that some
people who come to our hospital had
borderline diabetes or pre-diabetes but
in a more recent study italian
endocrinologist paulo fiorina found
hyperglycemia or high blood sugar was
revealing itself in hospitalized covett
patients who had no predisposition to
diabetes hyperglycemia can be included
in the long-covered syndrome spanza
who's been suffering long-covered
symptoms since march says medication
diet and exercise has been controlling
his blood sugar feels like it's suddenly
like from the middle of october it feels
like it suddenly has been dropping off a
sign experts hope the disease is
reversible as they continue to unravel
another coveted mystery jamie morocco
global news toronto
still ahead the rush for a holiday
staple in short supply
if you're hoping to get a real christmas
tree this holiday season be prepared
there's a countrywide shortage this year
partially due to extreme weather nova
scotia and quebec dealt with late spring
frost ontario saw a dry summer and fall
summer temperatures in b.c and alberta
soared and as christian robinson reports
the recent flooding out west has only
made things worse
everyone and their dog is on the hunt
for the perfect slice of holiday
tradition
just to make sure we have a chance to
get a tree because don't know what it's
going to be like this year tend to react
as consumers but
you just never know the canadian
christmas trees association says there's
a supply shortage across north america
driven by increased demand during the
pandemic
but the odds are also stacked against
growers and sellers in the pacific
northwest unfortunately b.c has been hit
very hard this year with weather
extremes the summer heat dome and now a
flooding disaster for 10 years you know
you have nurtured those trees and then
for this to happen it is it is
devastating these rains
and that heat dome we've never had that
in our lives gord ferguson's richmond
lot is stocked 75 percent of his pre-cut
alpine furs arrived from merit before
the storm but his delivery guy was
stranded for days
there's still 100 trees of mine sitting
in his yard i never thought it was such
a bad little tree all of his cheaper
charlie brown trees are stuck in
cranbrook due to highway 3 delays
i've never seen anything like this at
this time of year
arthur lowen has been growing trees
since 1970.
these were underwater in chilliwack for
a week but will survive with the highway
back open customers are returning and
he's able to ship his cut wholesale
trees
heavy rain is not going to stop us lowen
expects to lose up to 1 000 younger
trees our temperatures hit
45 degrees much of bc's inventory comes
from washington and oregon also hit hard
by high temperatures
canada's 100 million dollar a year
christmas tree industry exports about 49
million mostly to the u.s
with u-cut farms expected to run out
early you may want to secure the stock
and strap it down before it's too late
kristin robinson global news
vancouver and that is global national
for this sunday night i'm robin gill
around the world menorahs are lighting
up to mark the first night of hanukkah
so we leave you with this giant 700 foot
led menorah in miami it will be lighting
up the florida skyline during the eight
nights of the jewish festival of lights
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
i'll see you next weekend
[Music]
you